that's megan fox and to machine gun
kelly on a romantic getaway it's really
beautiful actually and no arguments here
megan shared these photos to instagram
on thursday showing off their european
vacation the newly engaged couple
captured some precious moments while
exploring the streets of italy that's
hard to top that one man while other
pics showed off their romantic sunset
boat ride megan's brief caption
confirmed the landmark locale simply
writing quote lake cuomo the actress
took to her instagram story to show off
their party on the lake courtesy of
machine gun kelly's camera work
the italian getaway follows the couple's
epic engagement announcement last week
megan shared this montage of the big
moment
according to her caption the couple
apparently drank each other's blood
following the proposal meanwhile mgk
shared this close-up of megan's
two-stone engagement ring the singer
provided some backstory in the caption
writing quote the emerald her birthstone
and the diamond my birthstone set on two
magnetic bands of thorns that draw
together as two halves of the same soul
forming the obscure heart that is our
love
and the rapper later revealed another
fun fact about the ring i
worry about the weirdest things well
megan you don't need to worry about
losing your ring in his interview with
vogue magazine this week mgk revealed
the bands are actually thorns so if she
tries to take it off it hurts the rings
designer stefan webster gave e.t all the
details on those unique features
the two throne rings are crafted in 18
karat white gold with white colorless
diamond pave set with a pear-shaped
untreated colombian emerald and a
pear-shaped d-color antique cut diamond
on the other it's the most talented boy
in the world megan and machine gun kelly
got engaged after dating for less than
two years the couple met on the set of
midnight in the switch grass in march of
2020 romance rumors began when they
appeared out and about together shortly
after and when she appeared in his music
video for a bloody valentine
as news of their engagement broke last
week a source told et quote mgk has been
telling his friends how megan is his
dream girl and he's always trying to
make her happy and do romantic things
for her his proposal plan was no
exception and he wanted it to be very
special the two of them are so ready and
excited to continue their journey as a
couple and create more memories together
[Music]